[Applause]
that's new
like that I can't believe this first one
didn't snow I think it's a great coffee
tale book but no one wanted it check it
out it's called shockingly candid
fortune cookies that's just a whole book
of them look at that only six people
what could it be you know check this one
out right here your husband is gay and
afraid to tell you look at this one down
here you have an unpleasant odor Gary
[Applause]
you believe no one bought that look at
this one this is a whole coffee table
book of age-appropriate laptop stickers
age-appropriate laptop stickers look at
this guy there it's got a cialis his
Rogaine his Dole Kemp yeah look at the
back cover this is pretty good mitt
pretty good baby here's kind of a weird
one I can maybe see why this one did the
sell it's a whole coffee table book of
unconvincing mouse disguises
unconvincing disguises yeah just not
really and you can tell the mouse knows
it's not going over and then look at
this one right here that's and then look
at this one right here
here's one Betsy DeVos identifies common
school supplies yeah here's one right
here there she is saying that's kickball
yeah here she is saying space abacus
[Applause]
this is last one right here
science blah I can't believe this didn't
sell cuz I was personally invested in
this one conan's were selling accordion
albums look at this one right here
here's my fifty focus about boiled
onions right there yeah no one wanted
that one check this one out
journey to accordion topia and here's my
favorite album ever
doctor squeeze and finally there was
this book why was that left at their
grave look at that right there who puts
that cut out Crocodile Dundee what does
that even mean I give this one I don't
understand
[Applause]
yeah and then what's that all about
just some coffee table books that didn't
sell it sure didn't
you